it's time now for CBS morning's deals
this morning we have three items that
may help make your holiday season a
little easier and better all at
exclusive low prices to start shopping
now go ahead and scan that QR code on
your screen right now you see it right
there or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle
expert Elizabeth Warner joins us right
now what's up Liz thank you so much for
having me back of course so what do you
have do you like being called Liz that's
fine okay
so this is an award-winning set for
children that allows them to dream and
create their own video games so these
books take them through design concept
they're actually going to draw their own
games they take a picture of it it then
becomes an actual video game that
they're going to be able to play so
we're talking about art creativity
dreaming imagining they create all the
characters in the game the obstacles
they can jump they can move this is an
amazing item recommended for ages six
and up it's all color-coded what's the
name and it's it's called pixiecade
that's cool essentially teaching them
stem it is STEM Science technology
engineering arts and math we call it
steam if we add the Arts in and this has
the Arts as well so that is awesome this
is really amazing so today two for the
price of one 19.99 so for ten dollars a
set these are amazing amazing
they're learning while they're playing
which is perfect I love that um so you
might recognize a little bit of this yes
so this is the K Carol accessories these
bags are absolutely gorgeous this one
happens to be on Oprah's Favorite Things
yes and because I told someone a nice
sized tote and comes in a bunch of
colors that's right oversized
everything you wanted that's right
that's the Taylor tote which by the way
her daughter got married and her new
last name is Taylor so they named the
bag after her daughter 15 by 15 by 18. I
love all the pockets in it yeah I was
going to say it has a lot of storages
because y'all be putting everything
a lot of stuff women own business
sometimes it looks like a trash can no
no I gotta do better I do I have to do
better okay how much is this one yeah so
these actually uh all the bags are 33
off starting at just 26 dollars
the tote itself is 39.99 yeah they have
all different bags and sizes so go we
have them all all check them all out
they're all 33. use this as a nurse yes
you can in that nice plaid feel me I
like it did you carry it back I've seen
your backpack I've seen your backgrounds
your wallet a passport yeah sure I like
it in the Plaid all right and it looks
good on YouTube that one's yours all
right so a little walking dip
this is you okay I almost tripped on the
cord but guys this is masingo no
tripping alone let me turn this on for
you this is a karaoke machine they are
known to make the best of the best okay
[Music]
but my eyes are supposed to be singing
with me here I don't know if I know this
song these are amazing
all right okay
they're hairy style uh well you know
what we know we got the right we
actually weren't allowed to do that but
all right so check it out yeah it's got
two microphones
[Music]
PA system microphones the microphones
actually are amazing you turn them on
you've got volume control Echo the whole
deal you can plug these in charge them
I do like the colors yes I do this is
going to bring your party up okay
how much is it so what we do with this
it's a Bluetooth we actually just put
yeah on the on your phone your tablet
you download the karaoke version and the
words pop up and you're good to go so
this is 30 off Jingle Bells keep going
ninety nine dollars yeah
[Music]
hey Elizabeth Warner thank you so much
and of course
all right of course we partnered with
all these companies to get these deals
you can buy anything you saw just scan
the QR code on your screen next time I
should rehearse or you can head over to
cbsdeals.com we'll be right back